Soviet researcher stabbed himself with a
syringe containing one of the most
dangerous and horrible viruses called
Marburg virus which is a bit like Ebola
but much more dangerous he died horribly
but of course you never let anything go
to waste and whilst he was dying
horribly the virus in his body was
changing was mutating so they took blood
samples and hey prester they ended up
with a new even more dangerous version
of the virus so that was sort of good
Matthew Cobb welcome to the show thank
you very much good to be here
how do you describe what you do for work
when someone comes up to you and says
what are you what do you do on a daily
basis what's your answer it depends on
on who they are and what I've been doing
recently uh technically I'm a I'm a
lecturer so I say I teach at the
University uh but I also write I
research I do all sorts of things
recently your fascination has been with
the genetic age you've called it a
perilous quest to edit life why perilous
uh because uh lots of things can and
indeed have gone wrong uh and part of
the point of the book is to highlight
three areas in particular of the
application of genetic technology that I
think are particularly concerning and I
think the public needs to be aware of
and political
regulatory Solutions need to be found to
respond to those dangers I had Rob Reed
on the show a little while ago you
familiar with Rob nope so he did a
four-part series with Sam Harris about
two or three years ago about the dangers
of
biotechnology bio weapons specifically
he was looking at uh is it BSG certified
Labs is that the what's the acronym I
don't know it's There's Something
Something level of accreditation that
different Labs have in terms of their
security yeah and he did this four-part
series and it was absolutely terrifying
who's talking about you know desktop
um did weapon creators basically where
you can synthesize particular sequences
and it all goes up to a cloud and I mean
that that worried me quite a lot so I
was a relatively prepared I think for
more concern about it and given the
research that you've done do you see
Gene editing as a net positive at this
stage is it a dream or is it a nightmare
oh well in terms of what it can do both
for science and medicine it's quite
extraordinary I mean for the last 50
years we've had the ability to precisely
edit genes I mean humans have been
altering uh genes primarily
inadvertently uh simply by our presence
on the planet and our actions as
hunter-gatherers as Predators we've
changed the genes in animals and plants
uh and then later on with the
development of Agriculture and finally
uh selective breeding then we've
deliberately changed characters though
we didn't actually know what we were
doing so genetic engineering develops 50
years ago this Autumn and involves the
precise alteration of genes in a desired
way and that has been absolutely
transformational
however
uh there are these concerns and that's
they've been Perpetual throughout the
history of genetic engineering that's
what particularly interested me so as I
say there are areas that I'm very
concerned about and uh not so much
bioweapons as more generally gain of
function research as it's called which
we can discuss later on uh of dangerous
pathogens that's one thing that
particularly concerns me but I'm aware
that my worries are very similar to
those that have been repeatedly raised
over the last half century and have
turned out to be unfounded so it's
partly to explore uh this consistent uh
kind of promises and then fears and then
dissipation of the fears uh that we can
see over the last five decades
and that I recognized in my own concerns
today that's one of the reasons why I
wrote the book it's a permanent
Cassandra complex around the genetic
development yeah yeah and you've got to
remember that uh when Cassandra's opened
uh the Box there's something left at the
bottom and that thing is hope uh so you
know Cassandra doesn't just release all
the the horrors on the world there is
always hope and I think that is that is
true as well because you know to to
clearly answer your question the the net
is a net positive what genetic
engineering has enabled us to do uh if
any listeners use insulin or any of
their family family members use insulin
then that insulin has been produced uh
in a genetically engineered microbe now
insulin prices have not plummeted as was
promised when this was first developed
45 years ago but that's for a rather
different reason in terms of the
economies of scale and the safety of
what p people put into their bodies now
with the insulin that is produced
through genetic engineering that is far
safer than the previous versions which
are all derived from animals and weren't
identical to the human is that what
people were using before we had we could
synthesize insulin people were taking
animal insulin you take pancreas from uh
where else can you get it from I didn't
know how long we were able to to do this
well
insulin was developed as a drug in the
early years of the 20th century uh and
for decades therefore you were relying
on the supply of drugs uh supply of
insulin as a as a byproduct of the um
of the the slaughter of animals so you'd
extract the pancreas and then you could
get the insulin from that but that was a
very long process and above all the
insulin that is produced in pigs or in
cows uh has a slightly different
structure it's got one extra amino acid
compared to the human version and as a
consequence people eventually developed
uh kind of an allergic response to it
eventually cause problems when this was
the only form of insulin that had so
when the genetic engineers in one of the
earliest applications of this technology
in 1978 they made
human insulin or they produced they
produced human insulin with exactly the
same molecular structure in a microbe
this was a remarkable breakthrough
because in fact it was actually better
than what you could get on the market
was better than the previous solution so
just to take that one example in terms
of medicine then you know genetic
engineering the production of drugs
there's a new paper just came out
literally last week with describing a
new way of synthesizing an anti-cancer
drug which is a thousand times more
productive than the traditional way
which involves lots and lots of
different plants they put the plant
genes into a yeast and then they're able
to virtually produce the whole drug
they've got one final stage to make but
effectively this will transform the
production of anti-cancer drugs so in
terms of medicine this has been really
really transformational in terms of
science then it's hard to think of a
branch of biology which does not in one
way another rely upon genetic
engineering as a tool to understand how
organisms function so it has been
absolutely fantastic but it's not simple
you know it is a tool it's a technology
Technologies get applied they don't
simply sit in the lab they get turned
into
plants and Fields And as we know there's
been huge controversy uh over
genetically modified plants as to
whether they're safe they are they're
quite safe to eat but there has been you
know people aren't happy about them for
all sorts of reasons and this has led to
the as I said these cycles of fears and
uh excitement that carry on down today I
mean the repeated uh excitement about
the possibility of de-extincting
mammoths or
um filer signs which are
marsupial that lived in Australia and
went extinct about 100 odd years ago uh
I mean these are actually fantasies
they're nonsense I don't think you can't
we can't do a Jurassic Park and get some
blood from a mosquito in some Amber and
recreate no no indeed my a few years ago
my colleagues from the University of
Manchester uh studied uh mosquitoes in
modern Amber that was only a few decades
old and the DNA had all gone so who'd
have known that Steven Spielberg was
lying to us this whole time about
genetics Spielberg just wrote the book
uh it's just uh just made the film the
book was written by Michael Crichton who
who had form uh on uh under trying to
use uh or exploring the worries about uh
you know diseases and genetic
engineering and what's very striking is
that uh I mean Creighton's book came out
in 1991 the film came out in 1993 but
since then in this Century there's been
a kind of cultural acceptance of uh
genetic engineering and
it doesn't seem to be something that
people are concerned about so there's no
films made this Century there's no books
written this not even kind of you know
techno Thrillers like uh Jurassic Park
that have explored this there's nothing
about GM crops for example you might
have imagined that this would be a
source of uh excitation for Thriller
writers for filmmakers but it hasn't
happened and it strikes me that you can
generally tell what a society is
concerned about through the cultural
products that explore it uh if you think
of I don't know the steam engine in the
in the 19th century then the seam engine
featured not only in paintings but also
in novels and it was it was seen as this
this transformational Force which indeed
it was or the uh the threat of atomic
war in the in the second half of the
20th century and since the end of the
20th century there really hasn't been
much of any caliber EXP flooring these
dangers and it seems to me that
indicates that our eyes kind of gone off
the ball we we're not paying attention
anymore to to what's going on because
these things are extremely significant
and yet we don't seem to be preoccupied
with me I mean just the Jurassic Park
franchise tells you this because it
moved away from being the the danger the
potential of carrying out this genetic
manipulations they say in the film but
not in the book uh you know your
scientists were so busy thinking about
whether they could they didn't think
about whether they should and that moral
dilemma which is at the heart of the
film
the first film very rapidly dissipates
and all we've got now is the whole thing
is scary CGI monsters on the Rampage and
we know it's going to happen and you
know the ethics of it is neither here
nor there it's just turned into a a CGI
Fest so there's something happening in
the in the global Consciousness in our
Global awareness that is indicates uh a
lack of concern and that might be well
that's fine I mean you don't get you
don't get many Thrillers uh about
railway engines anymore though I there
was just a film just came out recently
so you know maybe uh maybe maybe there
is still that lurking concern about uh
about trains Atomic power atomic war we
despite recent events doesn't seem to be
particularly concerning anymore so maybe
people are just accepting this but as I
say there are these three areas
of recent development which are both
very exciting but also very alarming
that I think uh suggests that we should
be alarmed and we should be concerned
the difference between could and should
is a very interesting distinction I
think for almost all of human history
our capacity to do things has always
been lower than our desire to do things
right like technology has lagged behind
the things that we've wanted to be able
to create and it's only recently that
we've got to the stage where technology
has perhaps surpassed our wisdom it's uh
Eric Weinstein where he says
um where gods were just shitty Gods
which is the same as saying Wegmans were
God's but for the wisdom the fact that
you have the opportunity to create
something on a desktop synthesizer which
could have some pretty big ramifications
up until the point at which you could
create it your could is below your
should and now it's the other way around
you can create things that you maybe
shouldn't do well yeah I mean I'm not
quite so worried about
um basement hackers and biohackers that
that's something that everybody got very
excited about about 10 15 years ago and
in particular the security services when
uh they feared that people would be
creating smallpox in mum's kitchen or
something whatever and and it is
incredibly complicated I'm not what you
know that I mean for a start the
biohacker movement is largely kind of
faded away and people aren't anywhere
near as excited about it uh as they used
to be but one of the reasons being is
that it's very very hard so for example
when scientists develop you know they
they synthesize the polio virus from
scratch that was on the basis of a
Laboratories decades-long experience of
working with these tools so even if you
can imagine a DNA sequence that could do
something terrible and you can get it
synthesized
then what do you do you've got to
introduce it into some organism which
then has to express that uh particular
protein in in some way and then it has
to be turned into a vehicle turned into
a way of actually transmitting this
stuff so even if you had you know very
strong malicious intent it's not
something that is easy to do uh and I'm
much more concerned about
established Laboratories uh carrying out
research under conditions that may not
be optimal or about uh governments
carrying out
you know clandestine military research
which then goes awry I think that's much
more worrying in terms of of Bio weapons
I'm not terribly concerned about
biohackers but it it is the case that uh
in fact the the the West security
obsessions about this which grew
enormously after 9 11. 911 is really the
kind of hinge around which a lot of This
research developed
the Soviet Union had been carrying out
uh bioweapons research from the
mid-1970s onwards uh without anybody
knowing uh what was going on this became
apparent and towards the end of the
1980s when a serious defectors revealed
to the West what had been going on uh
with the collapse of the Soviet Union
there was great concern that this might
get into the hands of Rogue States and
terrorists and all the rest of it but
after 9 11
which coincided with a series of
breakthroughs being made by researchers
for example some Australian researchers
who were trying to deal with the problem
of wild mice uh in Australia which are
devastating to the local marsupial
animals that live there so they were
researchers who you know their their
ecologists uh they were trying to find a
way of getting rid of the mice and they
inadvertently made Mouse pox which is a
disease very similar to smallpox but it
only affects mice they inadvertently
made Mouse pox immune to vaccination and
it was very obvious that if this worked
in Mouse pox the same procedure could
make smallpox immune to vaccination and
that is incredibly alarming
um and their researchers were so
disturbed by what they found that for 18
months they discussed and debated and
Australian defense Ministry got involved
as to where they should even publish
this this stud body so when all this
happened and coincided with 9 11 and the
terrible uh catastrophe there and
terrible and fears all around the West
about terrorists and so on
uh there was this big it also coincided
with the uh the SARS outbreaks in China
in 2002 and 2004 so it was the
development of an understanding that
there would be spillover events from uh
natural diseases in animal populations
just as it happened in 1918 with the
Spanish Flu
and
repeated concerns in the west about oh
this technology is incredibly easy to
use we should really be worried about it
because you know any old fool can do it
and eventually the very people you might
imagine
would pay attention to that did indeed
because after the fall of al-Qaeda in
Afghanistan uh U.S forces discovered uh
documents written by some of their
leaders saying uh that the enemy kept on
telling us that this was such an amazing
easy technology so we decided to try now
they failed I'm glad to say uh but they
failed primarily because it is in fact
much harder than the very simple
descriptions that are made in in the
media and by security agencies and so on
it's very hard first to master the
genetics and secondly to then weaponize
the particular thing that you may have
created is there not a concern moving
forward that as technology becomes more
developed and these systems inevitably
have more of the Kinks worked out that
that will democratize this danger a
little bit more that someone may be able
to in 50 years have a desktop
synthesizer which is as easy as the push
of a button to microwave a meal to be
able to create smallpox
um well that is indeed possible and
there are various solutions to this
because you can't you know you can't
unlearn
what we know you can't uh part that this
is the contradiction uh that science
thrives on uh being open and sharing
resources and information and yet there
are things that we can do that are
extremely dangerous uh now you can't
make a a nuclear reactor a nuclear bomb
in your back Garden
um but you could I mean I could you know
you I can I'll accept your fantasy that
in 50 or maybe 100 maybe 200 doesn't
matter how far in the future that such a
device uh might be possible so then the
question comes of how you regulate
access to such things when uh there was
this kind of panic in the beginning of
the century then there was all sorts of
discussion uh about whether you should
limit the access to uh DNA synthesizers
because now uh you can actually you
simply give the give the machine
instructions and it will produce a
sequence of DNA uh corresponding to that
as I say the issue is not actually
sequencing the DNA and all sorts of
journalists of you know sent off for
bits of smallpox from uh various
Laboratories which then send the DNA
sample through the post but you know DNA
is inert it doesn't actually do anything
on its own it's got to be put into a
cell which then has to understand the
instructions that's being given and that
step
is remarkably difficult and it requires
not just abstract scientific knowledge
which it can indeed gain from a textbook
you can understand what how to do it but
actually doing it and carrying out the
procedures uh in an effective way that
is really really hard and any scientists
so we all know about PCR for example uh
polymers polymerase Chain Reaction we've
all had PCR tests during the covert
pandemic but any researcher
who starts working on PCR the first
thing they learn is that it never works
and even if you've got the whole
protocol set out and you know exactly
what to do you carry it out and then
nothing happens it is very very
complicated very subtle and you need to
acquire very good laboratory skills now
you could acquire those skills and turn
evil or you could be recruited by
somebody who was evil so I'm not
disputing that this is uh possible
but it is not at the moment any I mean
it is it's very striking that despite uh
bio weapons being as old as genetic
engineering itself so 50 years as soon
as the technology became that even
before the technology was a reality when
it was still
a a hypothesis uh the Soviet Union
agreed to start building and investing
in such things
um none of these bioweapons have ever
been deployed either by a state or by uh
terrorists so it is clearly a bit
trickier than
it would appear on paper but that
doesn't mean to say that we shouldn't be
worried about it because all these
things are held in Laboratories just
like there are two stocks of smallpox or
maybe more uh you know last November a
Laboratory um somewhere in the Midwest
of America suddenly discovered in its
freezer a whole load of smallpox samples
that were supposed to have been
destroyed decades early about that
that's absolutely terrifying uh and you
know it's they've people have tried to
reactivate smallpox using either body
parts preserved in formalin or corpses
that were buried in the tundra during uh
yes I read about that as well yeah and
so this is rather alarming that you
might be able to well for a start global
warming might lead to you know zombies
small smallpox Parts floating down the
street you know emerging well you just
got to get the small box emerging from
the from the ground I mean I think this
is very unlikely but it is not
impossible I mean it's something thing
not another thing to worry about I don't
think people should start
yes but it shows the kind of problems uh
that there are but the technology I'd
emphasize the technology is one very
simple to describe and to understand but
extremely difficult to actually apply
there's a an aspect of the of uh what
what what French sociologists and
science who study this to see how how
people in the laboratory actually do the
experiments it's the the ability to
manipulate what the french Court La
gestuel that the gestures the the skills
that you need to acquire to make the
experiment work are often really really
quite complicated and can take years and
years to acquire what are some of the
biggest close calls that the world's had
with dangerous Gene editing that you
discovered during your research then
well I don't think there's been
the main thing that has been worrying
has been the gain of function research I
think the starting point is that
um
genetics is different from every other
science
uh in that on four occasions
scientists have been so concerned by
what they're doing by the research
they're carrying out by the implications
of what they've discovered that they
have called for a pause a moratorium on
research and that's been applied
and no other science has ever done that
I mean science has done some amazingly
destructive things most notably Atomic
power so when the scientists were making
the uh nuclear bomb in the Manhattan
Project after the fall of Nazi Germany
uh there was a big discussion about
whether they should carry on because the
worry was the Nazis were going to get a
bomb and they'd kill everybody and so on
but with the fall of Nazi Germany it was
obvious that Noah the Japanese were not
able to emulate that and so there was a
big debate about whether they should
continue and although there was an open
letter uh written to President Roosevelt
it was never actually developed never
actually delivered and the scientists
carried on so although there was some
debate they never stopped work whereas
as I say four times geneticists have
actually stopped work first at the very
very beginning in 1971 then again in
1974 when they were concerned that this
might lead to for example uh the an
epidemic of cancer causing genes uh
because the viruses that they were
manipulating were potentially
cancerogenic that turned out not to be
the case and almost certainly the
viruses in fact don't cause cancer uh in
humans but those concerns were the ones
that led to the current levels of
biosecurity which still hold today and
as long as you follow them to the strict
letter then all should be well but
things can go wrong
um in 2012 Ron foucher who is a
virologist who'd been carrying out
what's called gain of function research
as I mentioned earlier this became very
fashionable after uh in the early years
of this century when both the the
prospect of future pandemics and the
fear that bioterrorists or Rogue States
might start using this technology led to
the U.S in particular funding research
where dangerous pathogens were rendered
more dangerous now this wasn't military
research it was all funded for example
by the National Institutes of Health in
the USA and the idea was okay we're
going to have a pandemic
once that virus arrives it will mutate
we've seen this with the Coronavirus
with Kobe 19. once that virus arrives it
will mutate if we can predict
how it is going to become if it how it
could become more dangerous then we'll
be forewarned and forearmed that's the
argument so for example in 2011 Ron
foucher this scientist work in Rotterdam
uh he went to a conference in Cyprus and
he got up on the platform and he said
um I've done something really really
stupid those are his terms
um he had I and I quote mutated the hell
out of h5n1 and that's bird flu virus
bird flu virus is about 100 times more
dangerous than covid-19 the reason we
haven't had a terrifying pandemic of
bird flu virus a bird flu is because
it's only transmitted by touch so when
it has spilled over from bird
populations then it's been relatively
straightforward to deal with with strict
uh kind of Public Health measures
but what Fouche had done by mutating the
hell out of it was to make it now
transmissible through the air just like
covid-19 and he was so alarmed by what
he'd done he predicted what could happen
he mutated the virus he thought well if
I fiddle around with this part of it
maybe it will you know start to float
through the air and indeed it did
other researchers very soon did the same
thing he was so terrified by what he was
done that together with his colleagues
they
published an open letter saying right
we're going to stop doing this they said
for uh eight weeks it turned out to be
for about eight months while new bar
safety protocols were implemented but
that was very clearly a you know that
was a bullet we dodged if that had
disease had got out then we would be in
attack would have been in a terrible
terrible mess now there were a whole
series of uh leaks from various U.S
Laboratories from ordinary Laboratories
manipulating bird flu in in other ways
that led to a suspension of funding of
gain of research gain of function
research uh in the US but eventually
even that was rescinded and now there
are two or three such projects now those
seem to me to be really foolhardy the
argument as I've said is this will
enable us to predict the course of
future pandemics well
I think we can see that the way the
world responded to covid-19 was not in
any way shape or form informed by that
research it was of no help whatsoever
other routes had to be taken to
understanding and eventually to coming
up with a vaccine and in a handful of
cases uh to ways of ameliorating the
infection so I think the justification
for that kind of research and there's a
big debate in the scientific Community
about this uh I think the justification
is non-existent and I think that
research should be stopped because even
the safest laboratory can have
laboratory leaks I should mention in
passing that there is no evidence that
covid-19 was fabricated in laboratory
there's not even any evidence that it
escaped from a laboratory that had say
been cultivating it to understand it
better or whatever all the evidence we
have at the moment and this might change
in the future all the evidence we have
at the moment is that this was a natural
spillover event from a wild population
of animals just as it happened with SARS
in the early years of the century must
be said that identifying the SARS source
as pangolins took 15 years so it's very
complicated to identify the exact
sources such a spillover event and the
event that produced the uh spillover
that caused the 1918 flu pandemic is
still debated but was almost certainly
from cattle but even that hasn't been
actually demonstrated I wonder which is
more difficult to try and work out where
the Genesis of a hundred-year-old
pandemic came from or to try and work
out the Genesis of a three-year-old
pandemic that happens to be in China
controlled by the CCP I think that they
probably end up evening out at around
about the same level of difficulty yeah
indeed and uh a whole I mean the Chinese
bureaucracy has got an enormous appetite
for secrecy and there have been a lot of
missteps uh by funders and researchers
in the west which has led to a lot of
Suspicion and it's quite possible that
we'll never we'll never know uh oh yeah
talk about the U.S contributing to
funding of this particular lab out in
Wuhan yeah I mean they they fund all
sorts of research there's nothing
nothing it's not a conspiracy anymore
you know they funded Ron foucher's
laboratory in Rotterdam that didn't make
Rotterdam the center of some you know
highness project to do what I mean yeah
the interesting thing that I learned
from speaking to Rob Reed a few years
ago was
the number of different ways especially
when you're talking about uh gain of
function research uh genetically
engineered or genetically modified
viruses bacteria Etc the number of ways
that it can escape from a lab even the
highest security lab there was one story
he told me about which you might be
familiar with where the air conditioning
stopped working and backed up and it
meant that one of the particular vents
which is supposed to be shut didn't end
up being shut and a bunch of people in a
nearby town were infected with some
virus that Anthrax or something that we
thought we'd previously gotten rid of
there are so many where there's stories
of uh like the Classic Hollywood version
of the guy in the rubber gloves and he
cuts himself and something he ends up
being infected in that sort of a way
people putting it in their pocket and
walking out of the lab without realizing
these are at bscg 4 like the highest
level that you can get to and it seems
very much perhaps similar in the way
that the development of AI is behind the
control mechanisms to make sure that the
alignment problem gets sorted it seems
to me that the level of security Within
These Labs is inferior to The lethality
of what they're synthesizing within them
yeah I think the the fundamental issue
here is one of Regulation and control
now there is a structure that could and
should oversee all this and it's called
the biological weapons convention and
this was signed in 1972 so at the very
same moment that genetic engineering
became a reality and it uh came into
function in 1975 and apart from the fact
that both say the Soviet Union South
Africa which had very well developed
biological weapons programs signed up to
it and you know there's complete
disparity between what they were doing
in private and what they said in public
the fundamental issue with the
biological weapons convention is that
it's toothless it has no power of
inspection no power of sanctions so if
anybody were to
go out with its rules
so what uh and when there was the recent
uh propose about eight years ago I think
too hard to give the biological weapons
convention teeth a bit like the
international atomic energy agency which
is currently uh in in Ukraine they can
send in inspectors they can you know
everybody has to accept that they should
and then they can sanction stuff you
know it's been the cause of a huge
diplomatic Rouse uh with Iran for
example because of the powers of the
iaea
if the when there was a proposal to give
the biological weapons convention
similar inspection and sanction Powers
the USA
put a veto on it because that would
involve having inspectors in U.S labs
and they said if you come into our
commercial Labs or into our military
Labs then you will threaten either our
commercial Secrets or our military
secrets and therefore it's not happening
so there is a uh I mean I think this
issue of global regulation
uh which is very unfashionable but it's
absolutely necessary as we can see with
the iaea is one that actually underpins
all three examples of uh the current
dangers that are lurking within
potentially advantageous genetical
engineering research we need to have
ways of actually controlling it that are
not simply uh on paper but they also
involve uh people in hazmat suits going
into Laboratories and measuring air
pressure and the circulation and the
safety procedures and what exactly you
know going through computers seeing what
genes are being manipulated and actually
having a right of control over that and
I I think without that then their will
in the end be uh a problem now the two
examples you just gave both took place
in the in the Soviet Union there was an
outbreak of Anthrax in svered loftsk
which the Soviet Union insisted came
from
people eating contaminated meat but
which research is very uh going into the
going into the Soviet Union afterwards
showed in fact the air the the wind uh
passage showed very clearly that this
could only have come from a nearby uh
biological laboratory there was some
kind of leak uh in the second example a
Soviet researcher stabbed himself with a
syringe containing one of the most
dangerous and horrible viruses called
Marburg virus which is a bit like Ebola
but much more dangerous uh he died
horribly but of course you never let
anything go into go to waste and whilst
he was dying horribly uh the virus in
his body was changing was mutating just
like coronavirus can mutate within uh
people today and so they took blood
samples and hey Presto they they ended
up with a new even more dangerous
version of the virus so that was sort of
good that's all true it's terrifying but
all true
oh my God so uh comrade Friedman Over
The Far Side is in terrible pain but
while he's there let's use him he he
died as he would have wanted to live
creating new viruses there you go that
was pretty much what happened and he I
mean this was not just some hapless lab
researchers where I forgot his name now
as one of the head researchers I mean
it's absolutely awful I mean he would
have died in in a horrible horrible way
what was the fourth pause we've done the
first three two in the 70s one with you
gentlemen up on stage who yeah I
appreciate out of it yeah well the
fourth one the fourth one uh was in 2019
and
sadly it's not been as successful so in
2018 uh in November a Chinese researcher
called her John key uh went to a
conference on human gene editing and he
announced to well by then it wasn't
everybody's surprise because it had all
leaked in the few days before but uh he
announced that he had carried out a an
experiment he called it Gene surgery on
two human embryos and he had altered
their genes uh in as it turned out quite
most catastrophic way and that what he
had intended to do did not happen so
this is using the the technique called
crispr which is often portrayed as a
pair of scissors both met you know both
in words but also in pictures you see a
pair of scissors cutting DNA and these
are molecular scissors and enzymes that
were very precisely cut DNA and you can
persuade the cells uh DNA repair
mechanism to repair in a particular way
so you can alter genes very precisely
and this has proved uh since its
development in 2012 this has proved
quite remarkable in terms of developing
new scientific understanding but also uh
new therapies potential therapies for
existing people well I heard John Key
had done was rather different rather
than say changing the DNA in somebody's
blood cells to cure them of sickle cell
disease this has been done
experimentally
um what he did was to mutate the embryos
so these were when there was just a
single cell
he injected these crispr constructs into
the cells and eventually those two baby
girls were born he announced in November
2017 2018 sorry and then uh a year later
uh it turned out that there was yet
another baby so three baby girls so it's
just just that hearing that from you
about the fact that not only had he done
this completely pirated massively
lambasted completely unethical research
but that there was a third child yeah
that's only that's only just been
revealed there was rumors of it and now
it's been confirmed well it's probably
worse than that I mean anybody who's
going through IVF knows that you have an
awful lot of embryos
you don't implant them all
so who knows what's lurking in liquid
nitrogen uh in Chinese Labs now
there's two issues to this firstly uh
it's starting point is that there was no
reason to do it what he was trying to do
he said was to enable the girls to
resist HIV because there's a naturally
occurring uh form of gene in some
populations of humans that means that
people are much less likely to get HIV
now uh that particular mutation that
alteration is what he was wanting to
introduce
but if you've got that alteration one
it's not a guarantee uh you know what
there are plenty of ways of making sure
you don't get HIV and they're well known
and they've been well known for about 30
years now you know don't use IV don't
share your needles have protected sex
that's probably gonna be okay you'll be
all right
um so there was no actual need to go
down this route to genetic engineering
secondly the mutation that he was
introducing actually makes it more
likely that you'll die of other diseases
I mean there's very little that's free
in biology if you gain one way you you
lose in another and finally most
importantly what he said he had done he
had not done so he was trying to
introduce one particular change that
didn't happen the change he introduced
was still in this same gene but it was
to produce a change that has never been
seen in any other human being finally
the uh the girls or the two girls we
know have details some details of
um not all their cells are the same
so because you inject this stuff into a
single cell embryo you think okay that's
great then surely all the genes must be
altered yeah but the these crispr stuff
I've got to find this sequence out of
three billion base pairs they've got to
find where it is and then they've got to
chop up the uh the the DNA and get this
new piece of DNA put in in the meanwhile
this the embryo is growing that's what
anybody who wants to do it's it's
turning into a a a multiple cell
organism and as a result these girls are
what are called Mosaic the crispr didn't
work in every cell that the girls are
made up of so we have no idea what's
going to happen it may be they're fine
uh we don't know what the mutation does
we don't know what the consequences have
been Mosaic uh so anyway heard John Key
announced this uh very rapidly to a
horrific response yeah he's at a
conference I mean was did people Lynch
him
um there was kind of a stunned silence I
mean it was fascinating the uh well
there were questions people knew what he
was going to say because
um uh Antonio rigelado who's a
journalist with uh MIT technology review
he had written he'd spotted uh a in a
Chinese database he'd spot he'd
interviewed her John Key we talked to
him and he'd picked up there was
something going on and he found in a
Chinese database of clinical trials
evidence that this was going to take
place so a few days before the
conference uh it was all over the
Internet so when the conference took
place
everybody knew what he was going to
announce what they didn't know was quite
how bad it was everybody knew it was
going to be bad but then when the actual
results were demonstrated and despite
his claims that oh it's all fine and we
just made this particular change it was
clear from the limited data that he
presented and the main commentary on
this went on on Twitter in fact uh you
know that it was the hashtag crispr
babies uh it was literally what it was
called and you could see you know
eminent scientists who weren't at the
conference around the world watching the
live stream you know taking screen grabs
at the images he was projecting and then
trying to understand what on Earth had
gone wrong and getting absolutely
Furious in the meeting itself there was
it wasn't quite so uh there was no anger
although uh a Chinese a U.S researcher
called David Liu uh he kind of punctured
the whole thing by saying what was the
unmet medical need
because in any medical procedure the
first thing you've got to say is well
I'm doing this because there's no other
way of doing it you know you're not
gonna I don't know chop chop your leg
off because you've you've pulled a
muscle right I mean that would cure you
if you pulled muscle but it's absolutely
crazy so that question what was the UNM
medical need that those M normal healthy
embryos had there was no answer to that
um and her junkie didn't didn't give one
it's there were some researchers who I
won't name who initially said well it's
not so bad and it must be said that
around 50 people
knew what he'd done before it was
announced so these were people he talked
to in particular in America researchers
in America he'd gone around explained
what he was planning to do and then
sometimes he said well I've implanted
the embryos and so they knew but they
all nobody said a word I mean a few
people said oh that's really cool
um other people uh in their responses to
him uh said well uh uh why are you doing
this I don't want to know any more about
it but they still didn't you know they
didn't blow the whistle nobody went
public before this had been announced
um but eventually within a matter of
days everybody realized that this was a
really bad thing and even the Chinese
press which had initially said this is a
huge step forward for Chinese research
because China has a a deep uh eugenic
tradition as indeed as the USA
um and Sweden many other countries
um and or in an interest in eugenics so
their initial response of the official
governmental response was very positive
but within 12 hours uh all those web
pages had mysteriously disappeared and
her John Key was put under house arrest
he was then tried he was sentenced to
three years in jail uh he's now been
released but he's been forbidden from
ever working uh on uh assisted
procreation ever again so this happened
in 2018
and the response of many but not all
scientists working in this field was to
call for a five-year moratorium and in
February 2019 they published a call for
this five-year moratorium on heritable
genome editing so this is as I say this
is this is editing of genes that will be
passed on to the next Generation so
ideally every cell in your body shares
the same mutation including your eggs or
your sperm depending on whether you're a
boy or a girl and therefore those genes
will be carried on to the next
Generation so you've got to be sure
you've got it right
um and uh but not everybody agreed with
this so uh including one of the
co-inventors uh of crispr Jennifer
doudner she refused to sign this call
saying look it's too late you know
research has got to carry on but what's
striking is that I mean her John Key was
a a foolish vain man but he was actually
really doing what most of the scientific
Community had been accepting since 2015
because in 2015 once it became obvious
that crispr could work uh in human
embryos that worked in primates and
therefore it was clearly going to work
in human embryos
um the there was a big meeting in
Washington in December 2015 which they
said okay well we clearly need to have
Global consensus on this but you know
everybody's got to agree that this is
editing human uh the heritable part of
the human genome is what we should be
doing but
um nonetheless we think we should
establish what they called a prudent
path a prudent path to the development
of the application of Gene editing and
um
that was the that was the accepted
phrase we're on a prudent path a couple
of years later in the beginning of 2017
as her John Key was developing his ideas
was a big report by bioethicists in the
U.S which said which actually jumped the
whole talk of consensus so consensus
doesn't appear anywhere in the document
and it was just the prudent path there
was never any uh measurement or sense of
the importance of safety so all the the
dangerous stuff we've been talking about
the uh gain of function research I mean
those researchers are you know really
really aware of what safety is but
safety was never uh was never centered
and never mentioned as being in any way
definable as to you know what measure
what how many errors are you would you
find acceptable in editing the human
genome none a thousand a million we've
got as I say three and a half billion
bits of letters of DNA how many are you
prepared to see go wrong there's an
never any mention of that
so when this report came out in 2017 the
scientific press described it as being
an amber light to Gene editing so Amber
proceed with caution and that was what
her junkie took I mean he he was a bad
man he was working what was already
described as the wild east of Gene
editing at the time because regulations
were
difficult to understand or were unclear
in China plus there was a lot of kind of
turning a blind eye to regulations if
progress could be made there's a great
appetite for scientific progress so in
fact it was the whole of the scientific
Community I think well virtually not
everybody some people did say very
clearly do not do this and they put
their finger on the reason why you
shouldn't why would you want to do it
now the answer everybody gives nobody
want to get rid of genetic diseases
but you don't get rid of genetic
diseases by editing an embryo what
editing an embryo does is to allow a
certain human being to be born it
doesn't actually all you know until you
start fiddling around there's there is
no human so it allows that human to be
born and at the moment if you have a
genetic disease then you go through IVF
and you then do what's called
pre-implantation selection in other
words you test the embryo when it's a
few cells old and you take one of those
cells and you look at its DNA and you
see does this have the mutation that
causes the disease or not if it does
that would be an example of one of those
diseases
um well you I mean this is the kind of
thing that uh you carry out you you
could do this for example with um
Huntington's disease I mean Huntington's
disease is absolutely awful so
Huntington's disease is what's called a
dominant disease you just need one copy
of the gene you've got two copies of
every Gene you just need one copy uh and
if you've got that Gene then you are
basically it's a death sentence you're
gonna die almost certainly in your late
30s early 40s of a horrible
neurodegenerative disease now people
often know that there's hunting disease
in their family
so even if they are affected
they can have a healthy child if they
only have one copy of the gene the vast
majority of people only have one copy of
the gene they can have a healthy child
by doing this pre-implantation selection
so couples who want to have a healthy
child or a non-affected child
um can do this at the moment through
this technique and you've got to go
through I mean the horrible bit of this
is IVF is anybody who's done IVF knows
sorry just I'm not familiar with IVF and
why it's horrible what what's horrible
about IVF okay well uh basically so IVF
is in vitro fertilization so you make a
test tube baby so you've gotta I mean so
as a bloke uh yeah you producing the uh
the genetic contribution that's not
particularly problematic
whereas if you're a woman you'd know
yeah so you've gotta as they put it
harvest the eggs now normally a woman
will produce just one egg maybe two but
generally just one egg a month you need
hundreds of them so basically you have
to be filled full of hormones and then
they have to stimulate the release of
those eggs they have to collect them
well this is incredibly invasive it's
stressful because uh depending on where
you live I mean you're incredibly Rich
then you can carry on doing it as long
as you can stand it uh in the UK for
example then you will get three goes
there's three rounds of IVF
um and if it doesn't work then the the
National Health Service won't pay for
you uh to do that anymore you have to go
private and it's very very expensive so
uh it is extremely stressful and
unpleasant for the woman and despite the
my jovial remark it's very stressful for
the uh the the partner the male partner
as well because you want to have a baby
so it's that desire that in fact is
being treated here because as I said
normally you would go through IVF and
pre-implantate if you know you've got a
genetic disease go through IVF have
pre-implantation selection
find the right eggs put them into the
mother and if all being well you'll
produce a non-affected baby
now the only people
who could have their desires to have a
non-affected child met
by genetic engineering
would be those couples either where
you've got a recessive disease like
cystic fibrosis where both
couples have two copies of the gene so
they can't give a healthy copy that you
might find in embryo because that's all
they've got or if you've got somebody
with
um
somebody with uh Huntington's disease
say a dominant disease where they have
two copies of the Gene and so all they
can pass on is an affected copy which
will then mean that The Offspring is
going to be affected so the question
then comes well okay so we're meeting
the desires of these people to have a
non-affected baby we're not curing
anybody of anything we're responding to
that understandable desire lots of
people want to have children all sorts
of people and overcome fertility for all
sorts of reasons it's absolutely
legitimate but how many people how many
such couples are there around the world
now the short answer is we don't know
but uh the people who work in this field
doing genetic counseling virtually never
meet people in either of those
categories they are incredibly rare I
think there are two or three couples in
the USA who where both people are
homozygous for Cystic Fibrosis that's
one of the most common uh genetic
diseases so we're talking about maybe a
couple 100 pairs of people around the
world and this procedure would be
adopted in order not to cure anybody of
anything but to meet their desire
to have a healthy baby and there's no
right to have a healthy baby that's you
know it it doesn't work that way so it
seems to me and indeed even the
bioethicists who five six years ago was
saying well maybe it's not so bad I've
actually gone oh wait a minute why would
we want to do this in fact
the only people who could be helped by
this are you know very very few people
we're not actually we're just helping
them to meet their desires not actually
doing anything more fundamental than
that so I think for all those reasons
coupled with the fundamental problems of
safety because we now know that this
pair of scissors crispr is in fact much
more complicated or rather the way that
the cell responds to it can cause all
sorts of strange things to happen so
cells go through a cycle of quiescence
and then Division and so on and depend
on where there are they are in the cycle
they will respond in different ways to
having these molecular scissors shoved
into them and bits of their DNA being
chopped up which they've then got to fix
and we now know that in mammals in
particular this is very very sensitive
and uh in some cases so in human cell
lines so not in embryos but in human
cells
performing crispr particular points in
the cell cycle can lead to the loss of a
whole chromosome right you've got 23
pairs of chromosomes so roughly you know
five percent of your DNA just disappears
it gets chewed up by something that
isn't quite a pair of scissors and is a
bit more like a chainsaw gonna Mark so
people are begin to realize that the the
metaphors the precise exciting you know
seductive metaphors are in fact uh
hiding a really complex reality and so
for all those reasons uh I I agree I
don't think there's any reason why we
should do this and the dangers uh are so
extreme finally which you may or may not
consider it to be significant the
question is how is this technology going
to be uh distributed is it going to be
equitably distributed well I think we
know the answer to that
so you know it's not going to be a a
couple in an African village who have
genetic disease who are going to benefit
from this it's primarily going to be
rich Americans where this is legal it's
illegal I would point out uh in many
countries but not in the USA no way yeah
you can do it if you're in the USA and
you've got a load of money you can do
what you want
wow so State funding Federal funding
will stop you doing it because
um they're concern about stem cells
which is primarily based from the
religious right considering that stem
cell is a a human being with the soul
and all the rest of it you can't State
funding cannot Federal funding cannot be
used for
um stem cell research so that extends to
any manipulation of embryos but if you
don't need to ask the National
Institutes of Healthcare in your back
pocket and that there are institutions
that are like that and exist and indeed
they have carried out
some of the key steps towards human gene
editing heritable Gene editing in
private universities and hospitals in
the USA how close I mean
crispr I took on board the pair of
scissors that might also be a scalpel
you know it's laser Precision we can go
in and do the thing I was also aware
that
jeans it's not like this is the eye Gene
and this is the hair Gene and this is
the penis size Jean you don't just go in
and Fiddle around with an individual
thing it's often huge huge numbers of
them that that all are sort of
codependent and very interesting in
different ways how far away are we from
people being able to select an embryo
that's got a higher IQ or to edit an
embryo so that it's got blue eyes and
blonde hair if they want to have the
forthright come back around okay right
just deal with the eyes right so you
learn at school that um blue eyes are
recessive and brown eyes are dominant so
if that means that if you've got two
brown-eyed parents they could have a
blue-eyed child because the gene that
encodes for blue eyes is you know hidden
bowed by the brown uh potentially hidden
by a brown Gene
and this at school
genetics courses sometimes causes some
eyebrow raising because the opposite
conclusion could be made if you've got
two blue-eyed parents then having a
brown-eyed pair child will be impossible
because there's no Brown Gene there the
blue-eyed parents by definition
according to this view would both have
two blue jeans so all they can pass on
to their offspring are blue jean C
should have a blue-eyed baby and on
occasion where this isn't the case then
children have and can be quite
traumatized by that because it suggests
various things have gone on Parental
uncertainty going on there you go now uh
most recent thankfully uh that is
rubbish uh well stuff may have been
going on but you can't tell from eye
color so basically
more or less
I color is so complicated that with any
uh two eye color parents you can have
any eye color baby the reason being that
the latest estimate is that there are
over 60 genes involved in producing eye
color
so they're all interacting and a gene
isn't just doing one thing it's got lots
of you know it's it's a structure it's
got different bits of it are enabling or
shaping the protein it produces in a
particular way or meaning it's expressed
at a particular moment and all those
differences in those 60 different genes
are all interacting to produce the color
of eyes uh that you have and you've got
two copies of those 60 genes so if you
wanted to have a blue-eyed baby that
would be very very difficult you could
not guarantee it under current
technology so there are some companies
in America and again this is illegal in
the UK but in the USA uh you can go to
companies that say they will screen your
embryos so they do exactly what I was
saying earlier on pre-implantation
screening not or you can screen the eggs
and sperm if you wish but it's better to
do it on the embryo
and they will look for genes that
supposedly encode for intelligence or
blue eyes or stature or whatever but in
virtue I mean the the point about
diseases is that they are very
remarkable some of them because they
have they can have very very simple
genetic bases like Huntington's disease
which is just because you've got an
extra set of three letters of DNA that
is repeated that tags on to the end of
the Gene and that makes the protein go
wonky but most characters we have like
eye color certainly like intelligence
the genetic component of whatever
intelligence is is composed of thousands
and thousands of genes so uh you know if
people listeners want to give their
money to one of these companies okay but
you know I think you'd be better off if
you want your child to be smart then you
know have a baby in whatever way you can
and then give them lots of books to read
and encourage them to be curious and
that'll do the trick I think yes one of
the interesting things since learning
about behavioral genetics last year was
that a lot of people I think try to uh
retrofit their child to be somebody that
they wanted it to be whilst not
realizing that 50 of that child is made
up of that person there that stood
across that's sleeping in the bed on the
other side from you and yeah I mean
that's that was one of the interesting
things you mentioned the word Eugenics
earlier on I I find any uh accusation
around Eugenics especially when it comes
to conversations of behavioral genetics
completely laugh because you go well hey
why do you think you chose your partner
what are the physical cues of Fitness
that you were why is it that you think
smooth skin and good hair and nails and
teeth and all of that what what are
those cues of in bad breath bad breath
something that we associate with poor
dental hygiene well kind of but it's
also something else that suggests that
there's something wrong with your immune
system perhaps or that all of these
things that we pick is a visual form
beauty is eugenics that's what you're
choosing you're choosing an outward
version of Fitness but Okay so we've got
gain a function bad
we've got Gene editing bad
well Gene a heritable genome editing I
think is wrong yes uh and dangerous uh
and ineffective uh but editing of uh say
blood cells
is going to be is already experimentally
and uh will be clinically extraordinary
and if it can be rolled out cheaply and
to scale could for example uh resolve
problems of sickle cell disease which is
enormous problem uh for the
afro-caribbean community in the UK and
for uh Black Americans and indeed for uh
people in Africa this has got a very
simple genetic base single letter of DNA
uh that is altered and so altering that
in your blood cells where the the
hemoglobin is uh is present and
determines the shape of those blood
cells that is something that can be done
so there I mean you know it's the
heritable it's the passing On to the
Next Generation that raises the the the
the really problematic ethical problems
even even that haven't been said gene
therapy uh on say you know an existing
cells in your body has to be safe and
that is we're still a long way from
demonstrating partly for the reasons
that I explained earlier about these
perhaps unrecognized changes sorry yeah
I I have a friend who recently went to
a undisclosed Central American country
uh to get gene therapy for myostatin
inhibition done
so this is the Belgian Blue Bulls I
think have this this is the way that
they're able to grow such insane muscle
these Blues these balls look like Arnold
Schwarzenegger uh I think it's a country
which has autonomous zones within it
where medical ethics basically don't
exist it's a friend of mine that flew
down from
somewhere near where I live and got this
procedure done he's going back for a
couple more of these and he's getting
um
uh body fat analysis a ton of blood work
done he's going in for to get his Labs
pretty much every single week so yes the
the talk of elective procedures around
this now for the super soldier serum
from Captain America uh I think I
actually do think that Captain America
has contributed to an awful lot of what
people I'm being genuine no no no indeed
indeed that is the gene editing thing I
guess that's the closest one we've had
you know you have the super soldier
serum that's how they made him yeah
absolutely
um well I hope your friend's okay uh
Anna nothing's happened nothing's
happening happened so far we've got a
big balance big bag he does he does
indeed yes well then you know okay a
fooling his money and all that what what
were the other things
the third thing that I'm concerned about
is something which is again being
pursued with the very best of intentions
and I really want to emphasize this that
in virtually all cases the scientists
doing this work
are well intentioned they are not doctor
Strangelove they are not Victor
Frankenstein they're not trying to
create something awful the concern is
and this is a concern that they
generally share that things could go
wrong so this third area is our ability
to manipulate ecosystems so
you could people always say okay well
you know let's say malaria half a
million people a year currently die of
malaria so with all the DDT we spread
around the planet
with all the bed nets that protect
people at night from mosquitoes half a
million people die of malaria and you
know other mosquito transmitted diseases
are available but that's the big killer
and most of those half million are
infants children under five so why don't
we
alter the mosquitoes so either that
they're steriles or they go they
disappear or say that they're immune to
malaria they can't carry the malaria
parasite which sits in them not doing
them any harm but not doing them any
good until they inadvertently inject it
into us with their saliva as an
anti-cargill whilst the females are
biting us so if you do this I mean you
can imagine all sorts of ways of doing
this and really I mean let's let's say
there is a gene a single Gene you can
change single letter of DNA and now the
mosquitoes are immune or they're going
to become sterile so if you release you
produce lots and lots of mosquitoes like
this even if the mosquito has two copies
of the gene you've manipulated when you
release it into the wild that Gene is
almost certainly going to disappear even
if you produce bazillions of the down
things because there are even more
mosquitoes that don't carry that Gene in
the wild population and very simple
population genetics shows that over
relatively few Generations it disappears
so what are what people realized at the
beginning of this century was well okay
we're going back to the what I was
saying earlier on about cell repair
mechanisms
in certain microbes there exists a a
kind of parasitic bit of DNA that uh
produces an enzyme that will cut very
precisely at a location of uh the genome
and that location is where the DNA is so
what happens is that you've got uh one
copy of this Gene it's expressed it
produces an enzyme which pair of
scissors and it chops the DNA on the
other chromosome
the cell looks at this Gap in its DNA
doesn't like that cells don't like
having gaps in their DNA and it goes
okay I'll use this sequence over here on
the other chromosome as a model and I'll
copy that over and now hey Presto I've
got two copies
and this is called a gene drive because
now what you had a single copy you've
now got two in the Next Generation that
individual mates with uh an ordinary
individual in the embryo you've just got
one copy initially it copies over and
that when it hatches that offspring that
mosquito has now got two copies can you
imagine that on a population scale and
basically you've got exponential growth
so this Gene drive as you've called as
this is called was hypothesized by a
chat called uh Bert at Imperial College
in in London at the beginning of the
century and he was he was just thinking
about well you could do this is before
crispr was invented before Gene editing
was uh even been given a name but he saw
that this thing existed in microbes and
he thought well okay maybe we could
harness this in some way if we could
find a way with crispr that became a
possibility and virtually as soon as
crispr became a a technology so the big
in multicellular organisms so at the
beginning of 2013 researchers started to
apply it to think about how it could be
done and they were terrified
um so they realized that okay yes it
just goes off as two researchers who
actually published an article on this
they discovered it again by mistake they
were just trying to think we need more
copies of this Gene we're interested in
right they were interested I can't
remember the shape of a fly's Wing or
something and they wanted more more copy
more flies with that particular defect
and one of the students a PhD student
thought okay well maybe I could use this
way of kind of copying it over and okay
yeah and we can produce loads and loads
of flies like this and then they
realized what they'd done they basically
created uh what they called it the title
of the uh of the
article a genetic Chain Reaction this is
a genetic bomb it goes off if one of
these things were to get out then the
even a single individual assuming it
survived and mated after one or two
generations once you got up to several
dozen copies of this Gene in the wild
this would then go hey well there'd be
no way of stopping it so something that
started off
as an incredibly well-intentioned
solution to half a million people dying
a year to eradicate mosquitoes in a
particular area
um or to render them immune to malaria
that contains within it quite clearly
the potential for catastrophe because
you might say well who cares about
mosquitoes and the answer is well an
awful lot of animals eat mosquitoes
either as flies or as larvae in water
and although all the ecological Studies
have been done show that there's no
single Predator that relies upon the
mosquito any of these mosquitoes so you
know there's no nobody's going to die no
whole population of other animals gonna
get wiped out lots and lots and lots and
lots of animals in throughout the animal
kingdom we'll eat these things and if
some of those animals go even a little
bit hungry because the mosquitoes they
normally have now gone
then you end up potentially with
ecological disequilibrium at the very
least we don't know because we know and
understand so little about ecology so
we've got this potentially life-saving
transformative technology incredible
power
and you've also got the great concern
and you've also got the great concerns
from the scientists themselves again
who've raised the alarm about this and
said we need either to find ways of uh
ensuring that this will dissipate so
there's a way of all sorts of clever
ideas have been come up with so that
after several Generations this will stop
and that will mean the mosquitoes will
eventually come back because they'll
spread back into the local area but it
will mean that it will be limited in
space like being able to run an
experiment yeah I mean you know you do
it and then stop it would no longer
carry on it would require a certain
combination of genes and that would
eventually become disaggregated uh by
the exchange of genes during sexual
reproduction that's one of the ideas
um but this actually works this works to
produce sterility and it works in the
laboratory and you can make a whole cage
of mosquitoes disappear in about eight
Generations it also works in slightly
more naturalistic circumstances in you
know cages that are held on a lab site
but with access to air they can't get
out but they can they can breathe you
know I mean so it's a bit more realistic
so we know it will work and there's any
reason to think it won't work so the
question then comes who should decide
and then you've got all sorts of
problems because you clearly think well
okay
the people who are most affected this
should should have a say in this so the
local community so there's a group
called Target malaria which is kind of
Consortium of lots of researchers uh for
the more paranoid in which your
listeners uh it's partly funded by The
Gates Foundation with perfectly good
intentions because they want to get rid
of malaria you know and it's better to
use this perhaps than a load of DDT
which kills all sorts of insects
and uh in Burkina Faso they have been
discussing with local villagers who've
got a very high level of malaria lots of
their children are dying how can you can
would you agree to this in principle to
this ex a local release taking place
to which their reply was well we don't
have a word for Gene in our local
language most of the population is
illiterate so how are you going to
explain to local people what you want to
do because you want them to have
informed consent what's called prior
informed consent that they understand
what's going to happen so one of the
things they've done very clever has been
using theater so God they've done
interpretive dance to explain really
really
and what a even worse what a gene Drive
is I mean that still doesn't mean say
that people understand even after going
through the theater and the explanations
people are saying well how can a
mosquito be half human and half half uh
mosquito and how are they going to grow
as big as airplanes so there's still
some problem and even then after they've
done all this when journalists they
discussed with the local leaders and all
the rest of it when journalists went in
and talked to the local community for
example they talked to the women doing
the washing and they said what do you
think about this and the women said well
nobody talks to us about anything it's
the Menders decide everything so you
know communities are structured they're
not simple you don't can't simply talk
to the leaders and it's all okay so
you've got a problem about ensuring the
whole Community understands does
everybody have to agree or can you have
a simple majority uh and then you've got
the problem well okay they might agree
the government might agree
but in deciding this you could be
deciding something that's going to
affect the region
country
continent the whole planet you may
remember that during the Rio Olympics
was a bit scare about zika virus so zika
virus is transmitted uh by mosquitoes
and causes uh terrible fetal
abnormalities and it's still a problem I
mean we only heard about it in the west
because they were saying to athletes
don't you know go there if you are
pregnant or you're planning on getting
pregnant because uh it can cause
terrible uh problems
is still ongoing uh in South America but
the key point is zika lives in a
mosquito that shouldn't be in South
America it used to live used to be
confined to Africa where the mosquito
and the virus didn't cause any problems
because the virus wasn't exactly the
same the mosquito traveled over the
Atlantic because you know they lay their
eggs in any kind of stagnant water old
car tires put on ships for all sorts of
reasons travel across the Atlantic and
then the mosquito changed and zika
changed so even if you say okay the
village all understand they understand
Gene drives and all the rest of it
should they decide
for potentially the whole planet
so these are real problems and this is
what happens when you get technology
when we're not talking about scientific
discovery we're talking about applying
it in the real world in the most
complicated thing we know which is the
planet's ecosystem and although it's
quite possible that any such release
would be fine and not cause any danger
it might also cause catastrophe and we
don't know we really don't know all I
can do is emphasize that the scientists
involved take this very very serious
indeed these security protocols they're
coming up with plans that can establish
kind of up to 60 checkpoints before you
might do this nothing's been done yet
where you know you could say right you
know a bit like with the launch of the
the rocket the other day you've got a
no-go no a go no go decision point and
at any one of those 60 odd points you
can say okay no we stop it this isn't
safe and I think that kind of approach
with far deeper ecological understanding
full local community engagement and
above all International regulation we're
back there again yeah uh a part of the
problem is you know people have been
discussing this and saying God this is
amazing it's also very alarming and
American uh researchers in particular
have written an awful lot about it you
know very clever sociologists and
political theorists but they've got a
major problem because what they they end
up wanting to write about is the need
for international regulation like with
the AI aea as I mentioned earlier on but
the US government won't sign up to that
they will not accept it they don't even
sign up to the international criminal
court and as I said they've opposed the
biological weapons convention being
strengthened so I cannot see the US
government signing up to an
international structure that would
regulate the application of Gene tribes
even though I think that is what is
absolutely necessary so in every one of
these cases we've got really complicated
science rendered more complicated by
taking it out the lab and putting it in
the real world and then even more
complicated issues to do with human
society and politics and how we
understand who should decide these
things and my point of view is that all
this stuff is far too important to be
left to the scientists people need to
understand it the benefits the potential
benefits especially in terms of the uh
the kind of more safe applications I've
been talking about but even the
potential benefits say uh of Gene drugs
my position on dream drives at the
moment is that I'm very very concerned
about them on the other hand I do
understand that if this we could be so
certain that this would be safe or that
we could stop the multiplication of
these genes with great confidence uh
then yeah you would save
thousands and thousands of lives and I
don't think that's a negligible weight
in the balance that we've got to come up
with but I don't think I should be
deciding I think listeners should be
deciding public around the world
politicians need to engage with this and
so on we are Gods but for the wisdom
it's a very indeed very terrifyingly
potentially apocalyptic view of the
future depending on how much wisdom and
how much technology we have yeah
absolutely indeed that is the uh that is
the title of the um uh of the US edition
of of my book in the UK it's called the
genetic age in the U.S uh they took a
rather grander title uh because I I
quote Stuart brand who's the guy who uh
set up the whole earth catalog and who
is behind uh or inspired many of the
projects for the extincting for example
and in uh the second I think issue of
the whole earth catalog in 1968 or nine
uh he said we are becomers gods and we
better get used we better get good at it
and so they've called uh the US edition
of the book which is coming out in
November is called as God
a moral history of the genetic age now
I'm not really comfortable with the word
moral but I get what they're getting at
and it's really it's a real word it's a
critical history and I'm being critical
but that doesn't play well on book
covers so they put the word moral and no
great moral Arbiter uh and I'm probably
much better at finding problems than um
finding Solutions but if I can highlight
some of the problems then cleverer
smarter people uh can come up with some
solutions that we can all uh engage with
Matthew Cobb ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you're doing online and check
out your work where should they go
um not probably best thing to do is
follow me on Twitter at Matthew Cobb I
love it Matthew I appreciate you thank
you thank you very much it's been great
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]